-Welcome back, everybody.
I am here in studio with
Michael Che and Colin Jost!
Um, so --
I say we're back!
We're here with Col--
We'll get you --
-I thought we were
going to switch seats
during the commercial.
-I thought it wouldn't be good.
-[ Laughter ]
-He made the decision.
-Hey, you know.
-A lot of things have happened
since -- First of all,
thanks again for coming in.
Colin, really, thank you.
But since you guys have helped
me out with the shows
in quarantine
and you Zoomed in --
And I appreciate you doing that.
Since you've been on, Colin,
your book went to
"The New York Times"
Best Seller list, dude.
Congrats.
-Thank you.
Dude, he is a "New York Times"
best-selling author.
Don't you ever forget it.
[ Laughter ]
-Big deal.
-How's the house?
'Cause we were talking about
you bought a house last time.
-Yeah. I did buy a house.
-Ah-ha!
-Okay. Okay.
It's not a competition.
I mean...
-I haven't moved in yet
because apparently
it takes a long time to close.
I didn't know this.
-No, you can't just buy it?
-Usually, where I go to live,
it's an apartment,
and you give the money,
and then they give you a key.
End of transaction.
Now, like, with a house,
you have to, like, wait.
They have to make sure
that everything's up to code.
I don't know about any codes.
I've got to get a lawyer.
They got to take down a shed.
It's annoying. It's a mess.
-The shed wasn't up to code?
-The shed wasn't up to code.
They took it down.
I'm just going to put it back up
as soon as they leave.
-I cannot believe
that there is a code for sheds.
-There's a code for sheds.
-I've never seen a shed
and thought,
"That looks up to code."
-[ Laughter ]
-"That's a good shed."
-"That shed looks up to code."
-It's an outside closet, man.
Give the shed a break.
-I'm so happy that Chris
is there. Chris Rock hosting.
Do you have Chris Rock stories?
-I remember being backstage
at the -- at the --
When they did the benefit
after Hurricane Sandy,
they did it at
Madison Square Garden.
And I was there
with Bobby Moynihan.
We were going to do a bit
where he was Drunk Uncle.
And so we were
waiting backstage.
And it's all huge
musical acts, right, there.
The Who, Rolling Stones, all...
And we're waiting to go on,
you know,
and Chris Rock wanders over,
and he's like,
"Hey, guys, how's it going?"
We're like, "Oh, good."
He goes, "So, The Who's on now,
and then Rolling Stones
are going to go on,
and then between that,
they're going to
send you guys out there...
[ Laughter ]
...to do a comedy bit.
Is that what's happening?"
And suddenly,
we're like, "Yeah.
Yeah, that's what's happening."
He was like, "Hey.
Best of luck."
He goes, "I'll tell you
something. I'll be watching."
-"Yeah, I'm definitely
not going out there."
-My story's not as good.
-No!
-Your story's great.
-Okay, it's a silly story, but
one time I was doing "Top Five."
He had a movie "Top Five."
-Loved that.
-And I got to meet
Rosario Dawson
for the first time,
and I was smitten.
-Yeah.
-And I remember
her talking to me.
She was so nice to me.
And she was like,
"You look so familiar.
Do I know you from somewhere?"
And I was like,
"I don't think so."
And she was like, "Are you sure?
Have we never met?"
And I was like,
"I don't think we've ever met."
And I just hear Chris Rock on
the other side of the hall go,
"You're not sure if you've
met Rosario Dawson or not?!"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
"I know I've never met her."
"You're not su--
Have you met Beyoncé?!"
No, I've never met Beyoncé.
-[ Laughter ]
"How do you not know
if you've met Rosario Dawson?!"
I don't know.
-He is unbelievable.
I love him so much.
And then Jim Carrey
is going to, maybe?
-Yeah. Yeah.
You talked to him personally.
-It seems like it's possible.
There was a debate.
And it seems like people
were talking about the debate.
-Yeah, there was a debate.
Oh, my God.
-Seems like it got
pretty good reviews.
-Colin, it did not
get good reviews at all.
-I haven't read all the reviews
yet, but some of the ones...
-Jim Carrey playing Joe Biden.
-Yes.
-That would be amazing.
Maya Rudolph
doing Kamala Harris.
It's all a possibility?
You don't want to say anything.
You can't spoil it.
-Never know.
-That wouldn't be fun.
-We can't spoil who wins.
We can't -- We can't spoil it.
-You can't --
-Could be Jim Carrey.
Could be Sinbad.
-Sinbad.
Sinbad's not playing Joe Biden.
-I don't know!
I've heard things.
-"I heard some things."
-People are talkin'.
-It's going to be awesome.
It is Saturday night.
It is live. It is on NBC.
Best of luck. Break a leg.
I know you guys are brilliant,
and you've got to go up
and write some funny stuff.
So thanks so much for
taking time, coming here.
And thanks for being live
on behalf of everyone,
doing that for us.
Michael Che, Colin Jost.
"Saturday Night Live" returns
this Saturday. That's right.
On NBC with host Chris Rock
and musical guest
Megan Thee Stallion.
We'll be right back.